what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel so I was going through the
comment section of the previous video
because I do read you all's comments by
the way I do check them out from time to
time and usually for about the first
hour and then I just have to go back to
making videos so I can't really read
them all day but uh if you guys want me
to see your comments post them in the
first hour and and uh then I'll go
through and read them as best I can
granted there are so many of you that
leave comments that sometimes I can't
read them all but I read as many as I
can and somebody made a comment and said
hey you should do the story of Superman
becoming a Herald of galatis and I was
like that didn't hen that did
happen I was like that happened I forgot
about that okay so uh a little bit of
explanation because again every video is
someone's first video so we got to make
sure that those new fans don't get left
hanging uh when it comes to
understanding what goes on in the realm
of comic books so Marvel versus DC now
on my channel the concept of Marvel vs
DC is just as much pitting characters
from both you know publication houses
together as it is covering stories back
in like 1970 something maybe even been
in the 1960s uh Superman and Spider-Man
crossed over they met each other for the
very first time and that was really like
setting the stage because Marvel and DC
sat down and they said holy cow there's
a huge Market fores seeing like Marvel
and DC characters cross over the most
popular ones by the way nobody would
want to see like you know Mr Miracle
Scott free cross over with like like uh
I don't know like She-Hulk actually I
would read that
story I would I would read that I would
read Mr Miracle uh crossing over with uh
She-Hulk it'd be interesting because
they're both they both goof around but
the fact remains here that this set the
stage for Marvel and DC crossing over
more and more the problem with this was
that within continuity it was just sort
of uh it was just kind of out there uh
there really wasn't a continuity per se
now Marvel and DC created one with the
amalgam universe but even then that was
isolated it was literally just like
characters like Batman and Wolf Rain
combined into a single character called
darkclaw and it had its own history and
its own you know Mythos and all that
kind of good stuff but in terms of these
characters crossing over you know the
Fantastic 4 and Superman like we'll see
in the story it was just sort of left
like somewhere along the line the
ability came to these characters to be
able to cross over into their respective
universes and that's just sort of what
happened so it's the quintessential
example of suspending disbelief that's
what you guys have to do here you guys
kind of has to just suspend disbelief
and just assume that these characters
can cross over with one another but keep
in mind this is not official content for
Marvel or DC it's just kind of its own
thing like Earth 2 or Earth three or the
else worlds or the whatif story so uh
this one initially picks up after the
death of Superman it picks up you know
following the introduction of Hank
Henshaw Cyborg Superman it really deals
with u not really a lot of the Mythos
from Miss character but it deals with
enough that we kind of have to do a
little bit of explanation here but we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it
initially this picks up with Galactus
now the indication that Dan Jurgens
gives us here because Jurgens is the one
who wrote this the indication that Dan
Jurgens gives us is that galatis was
around Krypton the time it was destroyed
now he walks the line here right he
doesn't tell us that Galactus was the
one who destroyed it but he doesn't tell
us he wasn't he just kind of leaves it
to us to decide which one we choose now
we will get a definitive answer to this
don't worry it's not like Dan Jurgens is
just going to leave us hanging like well
maybe Galactus destroyed Krypton maybe
he didn't I mean he gives us an answer
later on but the idea here is that
Galactus is present when the ship of
Superman is sent from his uh from his
parents out of Krypton to arrive on
Earth but for galatis he realizes what
it is that Superman will become and uh
decides to create like a I guess like a
beacon or probe is a really good example
sends a probe after it to follow him now
this is the kicker this this is why
these stories are a little iffy because
the question is well how does Galactus
know that Superman being exposed to a
yellow sun means he's going to be imbued
with all these insane Powers because
when Superman first arrived on earth and
the explanation of him being exposed to
a yellow sun gave him his powers was
given to us as the superhero Community
there was no precedent set for this I
mean there was there was it wasn't like
this had happened before and Galactus
knew it would happen as far as we know
it's galactus's first experience here
but along the way when this satellite or
I guess this probe is sent to Earth
along the way is intercepted by Hank
Henshaw and Hank Henshaw grabs this
artifact that's contained within and uh
and we don't quite know what he what he
does with it at that exact moment but
from here we basically switch over to
Metropolis and this is really like just
you know Dan Jen say hey this is
Superman here's what Superman is about
Superman is like a stereotypical hero or
I guess the definitive hero you know
he's the guy that saves the day and so
on and so forth what he does here isn't
wildly relevant uh it's really just Dan
J and as who he is and the kind of
things that he does and the reason why
is because for a lot of people who would
go into comic book stores for the first
time and they wanted to get into Marvel
or DC they would suddenly see a
publication that says Marvel versus DC
or Superman you know and the Fantastic 4
and they would say well I mean if I want
to read Marvel and DC then it would make
sense to read both and so they would
grab this comic book and not only that
for those individuals who would read
this and nothing else it'd be a way to
introduce them to the characters which
is kind of weird because it would seem
like Superman needs no introduction but
the fact remains here that along the way
of dealing with this event that's going
on in metrop he's suddenly met by the
arrival of this artifact that was sent
by Galactus and it presents him with a
with a hologram of his father jel now
what jel says is you know we sent this
artifact after you were sent away from
Earth and basically Galactus destroyed
Krypton this is kind of the funny thing
here is because this makes sense uh in
the context of who Galactus is and what
he does but Dan Jurgens also directs you
know I guess addresses the contradiction
here in the sense that throughout his
entire publication history it's always
been Krypton blew up and Galactus had
nothing to with it you know because
there was no reason to crossover galatis
he was you know from a totally different
publisher and Superman ask this question
he says well for the longest time I
always believed it was because of the
fact that Crypton just was destroyed you
know for for natural means I I can't
believe Galactus was the one that did
this now the other half of this is that
Dan Jurgens plays it fast and loose with
the history of you know galatis in terms
of Superman knowing about him because
again it's just kind of a
pre-established thing that Superman's
crossed over I mean he has had stories
where he's crossed over with a Fantastic
Four and I think he actually crossed
over with Silver Surfer although I'm not
going to I'm not going to swear to that
but he simply just takes it as fact well
I know Galactus exists Galactus is in
another universe but it's entirely
possible he could cross over to mine and
if he did it's entirely possible he
could have destroyed Krypton and so in
the mind of Superman the question is
okay if Galactus was the one behind this
then who do I talk to and in his mind
he's like well there's only one group of
people who are the most knowledgeable
when it comes to dealing with galatis
and that's the Fantastic Four also in
the story Superman meets Franklin
Richards yes nothing amazing happens but
it's cool it's just cool to meet like
you know these two Powerhouse characters
meeting one another and that's why these
stories are so interesting because you
when Superman shows up uh or I guess
when when Superman heads over to the
Fantastic 4 we switch over to Franklin
and Franklin loves the character of
Superman and to me it's really cool it
really provides this sort of uh grounded
feeling to see Franklin Richards you
know like yeah I was watching Superman a
Superman's amazing you know I bet he's
almost as big as Thor or he's bigger
than Thor or something like that for
Franklin Richards as a kid to try to
take the concept of Superman and
correlate him to existing Heroes that
Franklin Richards is aware of is cool to
me because it reminds me of of us of of
us as readers in real life I wonder if
Superman could take on Thor I mean it's
just a really cool kind of situation
that's what I like about Dan juran's
writing is one of the reasons why you
know his writing's lost none of its
luster in his current Works in DC
rebirth but again from here we basically
just kind of pick up with with Franklin
talking to Ben Graham and again you know
this is a lot of of character Exposition
here not much action going on but it
does give us some context in the sense
that it shows us what the Fantastic 4
are doing and and that's part for the
course right you know when it comes to
these crossover stories with Marvel and
DC it's part for the course that a
writer will say well here's what one
character is doing here's what the other
character or team is doing and it just
shows us what goes on in their everyday
lives Reed Richards is just doing Reed
Richard's stuff you know sciency stuff
and and Johnny Storm's making fun of Ben
Grim it's all it's always pretty fun to
see but in the midst of their
conversations uh suddenly the alarm
system goes off and the idea is okay
someone's in the back of the building we
have to figure out who they are but
almost immediately after this happens
Superman makes his presence known now I
got to tell you guys it's so cool to see
Superman talking to the Fant Fantastic
Four I mean because it it's just fitting
isn't it I mean it's just it's it's
fitting you have the first major
superhero really like the first
superhero with powers with a costume I
mean granted we had Heroes before
Superman we had the Phantom you know we
had Doc Savage we had those guys but in
terms of traditional modern day
superheroes as we know them Superman was
the first and right now he's talking to
the superhero family you know the the
first family of Marvel Comics It just
fits it just feels right you know going
going through this I don't mean to to
get all fanboy Fanboy I don't mean to
get off fanboyish on this but um that
needs to be a slogan like I I really
hope you guys put that in the comments
Fanboy or I guess fan girl if if you're
a girl um but the idea here is that uh
you know in in the midst of Superman
arriving of course he's brought the
artifact with him and almost immediately
after this happens the uh the various
security systems of the Fantastic 4
start turning against them now the
Fantastic 4 are able to to take care of
these you know especially with Ben Grim
but what happens is the various
components and the various Machinery
begin to sort of uh come together and
coales into the form of Cyborg Superman
now this is where we need to get into a
little bit of explanation on Hank
Henshaw so Hank henshaw's origin story
is akin to the Fantastic Four right you
know in the sense that Hank Henshaw his
wife and a few other people had gone
into space toci you know they were
blasted by radiation and uh it was very
you know fantastic foresque in terms of
of how they came back the issue here is
that because of his encounter with
Superman Hank Hinshaw became essentially
a villain of the Man of Steel and so
when the time came around for the death
and Return of Superman it made sense
that the you know the the energy of Hank
kenshaw because that's really what he
was you know at the time when he was
impacted by radiation by the time it
came around to him you know with the
death of Superman and so on that that
kind of story arc he was essentially
Just Energy and so it made sense that he
would basically reconstitute a cyborg
body of himself and try to destroy the
legacy of Superman that's why Hank
Henshaw was the main villain of the
reign of the Superman story arc
following the death of Clark Kent and so
you know with with him having the powers
that he does he's effectively able to
just control Machinery he can make a
body for himself he can make Machinery
do what he wants to and it doesn't
matter what it is any kind of Machinery
from anywhere the cool thing about this
is that Dan Jurgens was you know the
Mastermind behind you know the idea of
Superman dying how to bring him back
reign of the Superman so on and so forth
granted it was a huge effort you know by
DC with regards to all the Superman
titles and even stretching into Hal
Jordan when they were getting rid of him
to make way for Kyle rer but the idea
here is that for Dan Jurgens is kind of
a return to the to the house that he
built it's taking the character of Hank
Henshaw that he had such a huge hand in
evolving and saying let's apply him to
the Marvel un univers and so what this
tells us is that regardless of what
Universe he's in Hank Henshaw can
manipulate and control the very Fabrics
of uh of the Machinery in that Universe
not only that while they're in the
middle of fighting they're suddenly met
by the arrival of Galactus now Galactus
showing up here is him just here Dan
Jurgens doesn't give us this grandiose
explanation as to why he's here he kind
of leaves it to us to figure out and
basically what he says or at least what
we're kind of left to understand is that
he'd been tracking Superman and so over
the course of tracking him he basically
came to the realization that Superman
had arrived in this universe had met up
with a Fantastic 4 and shows up here not
only that because of the fact that
Galactus had looked into the future of
what Superman had become it was always
Galactus intention to basically make
Superman his Herald from the time he was
born up until the modern day and so what
he does is he basically just grabs
Superman and he says you are now imbued
with the power Cosmic you are now my
heral now the cool thing about this is
Reed Richards tries to talk him down
right he he says look like you're
Superman you come from a planet that was
destroyed all life on it you know was
wiped out with the exception of you and
of course korel or at least k world
doesn't really exist in the the post-
crisis continuity so at this moment
right now it's just Superman you can't
fall for this you can't be this guy uh
that goes around and helps to helps
Galactic to wipe out planets when you
yourself was a guy that healed from a
planet that was wiped out you have to
understand the irony here but Superman
is now a Herald which means that he has
absolute allegiance to Galactus for the
time being now the way the herald
pattern always works is something that
we'll actually see unfold here but it's
usually always a person's made a Herald
then they become you know under the
absolute control of Galactus and then
eventually they Rebel and that's really
where this story uh story heads in the
direction of but the idea is that for
Susan storm Hank Henshaw is still a guy
that can't be trusted and so she
initially imprisons him but because of
the fact that Reed Richards you know was
transported onto a ship alongside
Superman as the herald of Galactus and
then taken away by galatis it's really
just uh Susan Ben Grim Franklin uh
Johnny Storm and Hank Henshaw here and
so Susan says okay fine if you have
experience traversing the universe
traversing multiple universes then
surely you can get us to the location of
where Reed Richards is and hanken sh
says yes I can and so he's basically put
on a very short leash Susan says okay
I'll take you out of the the the force
field that you're in I'll take you out
of your containment unit but if you
stray even just a little bit I will put
you back in there and I will never let
you out I will keep you in prison
forever and so Hank Henshaw says deal
and so what happens is they basically
set off to meet with you know or I guess
to try to find Galactus uh Superman and
Reed Richards now from here we switched
to Galactus himself and this is actually
a really really cool discussion because
again Reed tries to appeal to Superman's
better half but the other side of this
is that there is an internal struggle
going on between Superman and uh him
being a Herald of Galactic because as we
know when it comes to the character of
soups you know when it came to the uh
Super Dad that's actually I jumped on
Twitter one day which if you haven't
followed me on Twitter you should com
explain I jumped on Twitter one day and
I was like now now the Superman's a dad
what should he be and people were just
like super dad so everybody wanted him
to be super dad so we're going to call
him that but um but with Superman as a
character you know he has an internal
struggle and that's usually how it is
with Harolds they always have an
internal struggle Siler Surfer had one
uh Nova Frankie way you know she had an
internal struggle it it's always the
same way they always have internal
struggles when they're inherently good
people and Superman is an inherently
good superhero but the issue here is
that he's not finalized as being a
Herald of Galactus and Galactus does
this he says let the transition be
complete and it seems as though Superman
is completely and totally bent to his
whim and so what he does is he basically
sets off at the request of Galactus to
uh to find him you know a planet that's
suitable and so switching over to
Superman we find a Planet that's totally
devoid of life but for Superman because
he's a new Herald his main goal here is
find a planet that can satiate
galactus's health because with the
Heralds of Galactus it's usually like a
learning curve you know when Galactus
says go find me a planet I can consume
they don't immediately translate that
into well I should find a planet that
will satiate Galactus for a long time
it's I'll just go find a Planet he can
consume and it's not until they're kind
of instructed in the ways on how to be
an adequate Herald that it really Dawns
on them okay I should just find planets
regardless of whether they have life or
not now Superman does find one of course
he does find a Planet for Galactus to
consume when they get there uh Galactus
starts tearing it up at the same time we
have the arrival of the Fantastic Four
alongside Hank kenshaw and what ensues
is uh is I guess what passes for a
battle and the reason why I say that is
because Superman lays waste to all of
them I mean he just crushes them hands
down the Human Torch Johnny Storm uh he
takes out the thing Ben Grim you know
but the whole time this is happening
Hank Henshaw wants to be a Herald of
galatis who at the very least wants to
possess the power Cosmic that Galactus
has and for him being able to attain
this would make him a guy that could
basically destroy Superman and then bend
the universe to his whim within the DC
continuity I don't I don't think he
really has a desire to take over the
Marvel Universe but in his reality in
the DC Universe he would have the power
to take it over in its entirety by
abandoning Galactus and so from here we
basically follow up with the defeat of
the Fantastic 4 Hank Henshaw and uh we
also have them trying to figure out you
know what the next step should be what
it is that they should do now of course
again Superman goes about finding the
fighing a planet that galatis can
consume and when he does he basically
stumbles upon a planet that has life on
it now the question he asked as this is
really where the inner turmoil comes to
a head he says are you really going to
consume a planet that has life there are
people here they have lives to live and
Galactus says yeah basically I'm going
to consume that planet because it's more
important that I exist than those people
exist now galatis isn't wrong he's not
wrong here historically speaking during
this time in Marvel Comics it was never
really explored but recently within the
last decade or so it was explored the
galatis doesn't like consuming worlds he
does it because he has to now this
really came to a head during Mark Wade's
run on the Fantastic 4 when we got the
abraxis Saga when it was Galactus dying
and abraxis basically uh being born now
of course that was originally a Louise
Simon in the story I think but it rolled
over into the main uh the main Fantastic
Four continuity and it was the idea that
following galactus's death uh he was
basically the gatekeeper for a much more
dangerous force that came in the form of
a braxus that was like the god of chaos
or the god of death or something like
that and just started like running
around the Multiverse killing off
galatis from all across the Multiverse
which we should cover that story the
death of all galatis like of every
galatis ever if that's not clickbait I
don't know what it is but the idea here
is that Galactus is right you know when
he says it's more important that he
exists than these regular people exist
because he's a force of nature he's a
fundamental part of existence so it
would be like saying eternity needs to
die in order to ensure that average
people can live the idea here is that
Superman doesn't like this Superman says
look I hail from a planet that was
obliterated when all life was gone and
you know the DC Universe is less great
than it could be because all those
people are gone because that technology
and that culture is gone and so
effectively you know he's he says
basically I've had enough you know I'm
not okay with this and so he essentially
turns against galatis now when he does
this isn't something that happens
immediately this is sort of a staged
event and the sense that the Fantastic 4
have caught up by this point in time not
only that you also have them trying to
distract Galactus but you also have them
trying to get Reed Richards out of his
containment unit now Ben Graham being
thrown into the containment unit of Reed
Richards creates a crack and because of
course you know Reed Richards has his
whole elastic form he can basically
squeeze through and he can get free and
what he realizes is that getting through
to Superman can't be done by brunt Force
because of the fact that the power
Cosmic has such a strong hold on him it
can't be done in any absolute way
instead they have to appeal to what it
is that makes him human and so in a
sense they kind of present him with this
toy you know that Franklin wiard's
carried around but it's Reed wichard
saying hey look you know Lois Lane those
people they depend on you for the hero
you used to be not the person you are
now you know ReDiscover your humanity
and in doing so he essentially casts off
the power Cosmic and this is a really
big deal because this shows us just how
powerful Superman is in relation to
galatis whenever someone casts off the
power Cosmic it usually destroys them it
usually kills them but Superman lives
not only that uh it really brings in it
brings him in alongside the Fantastic 4
and they start fighting against Galactus
now the idea here is that Galactus is
already in the process of creating his
world machine creating his device that's
going to consume all life or I guess
convert this planet and all life on it
into energy and so it's kind of a
multi-staged effort in one side you have
Superman who's as much a distraction
going against galactic as he is and you
know helping out Reed Richards but you
also have the group basically taking the
device of Galactus his his world machine
and turning it against him now Galactus
doesn't initially know this and the
reason why is because of Galactus huis
despite his position and seeing himself
as such an important part of the
universe he has a very strong tendency
to ignore those that he doesn't consider
to be as powerful as he is and that's
what happens he basically ignores A
Fantastic 4 and says whatever it is that
they're doing it's not going to matter
because by the time they're done I will
have consumed this planet maybe they'll
live maybe they'll die it doesn't matter
I'll find a new Herald and go on from
there but it actually proves to be his
undoing and the reason why is because
when Reed Richards turns the machine
against galatis when he activates it the
machine starts to absorb galactus's own
energies and so he's basically forced
you know with his back against the wall
with an ultimatum uh basically saying if
you stay here you're going to die you're
going to be obliterated because your
machine is essentially going to feed off
of you or you can leave and you can
allow this planet to live and so
Galactus doesn't really have a choice
here Galactus says okay fine then I'll
just leave and he takes off before doing
this and this is kind of the funny thing
is we learn that the device that
Galactus had sent in that probe That was
supposed to arrive and commune with
Superman was tampered with by Hank
Henshaw and Hank Henshaw was the one
that changed the device to send Superman
a message saying Galactus was the one
who consumed this planet and the reason
why is because if if Superman believed
that Galactus had destroyed Krypton then
Superman would have pursued Galactus and
that would have allowed Hank kenshaw to
basically travel with Superman through
this little technological device arrive
in this universe and then acquire the
power Cosmic of Galactus and so this is
what this is what H henra says you know
once Superman basically takes off once
he essentially leaves along with the
Fantastic Four when they when they get
ready to depart he tells Galactus give
me Perfection I want Perfection I want
to be the perfect being and Galactus
says okay and Galactus literally turns
him into this little compact box it's
got no working parts it's basically just
a simple piece of metal and it's perfect
in its own form you know it's it's
perfect as it's designed which is kind
of an ironic take on the situation to
give Hank Henshaw Perfection by turning
him into an object that serves no real
purpose an inanimate object essentially
and so this is basically just kind of
Dan Jurgens wrapping things up and as
you guys probably noticed he wraps them
up really fast he doesn't give much way
for expansion on what happens to Hank
inra because that's usually how these
stories are these stories are usually
just like hey here's something really
cool that happens here's a quick leadup
here's the cool event itself then here's
a really fast breakdown here's a fast
ending to it epilog and then we're done
and that's it and that's essentially
what happens you know Superman says okay
cool we beat galatis you know this
planet has been saved I'm no longer his
Herald Galactus is off doing his own
thing whatever he goes back to where uh
the Fantastic Forest base of operations
is and he gives Franklin Richards his
cape you know because Franklin Richards
is such a huge fan and then the story
ends with Superman presumably just
taking back off to the uh to the DC
Universe but you know these stories are
cool in terms of being able to see just
a cool situation um the issue is that
the writing doesn't really lend itself
to providing an adequate buildup and an
adequate ending it basically just
ends but if you guys are new here to uh
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the Subscribe button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video drop a like and leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about this story and if you guys
are interested in seeing me do more like
this but uh yeah I will catch you all
later
peace get money
[Music]
baby